[Musique]
et bien c'est un malin celui là comment
tu vas l'appli que des singes
vraiment tu crois il nous a sauvé la vie
il a été remarquable c'est toi tu es
césar de tuiles peur qu on cherche
quitte à votre au colonel nous ne sommes
pas des bêtes sauvages
90 5 cibles acquise
[Musique]
préparez vous à vous battre
il montre au prix
ma maison ma famille
et tous les jours des singes sont tués
humain est malade singes devient malin
alors humain tu sage mais n'est pas moi
je cours
il faut savoir renoncer à notre humanité
afin de pouvoir sauver l'humanité
toute l'histoire de l'humanité
à mener qu'à ses histoires
si nous le perdons
planète deviendra
la planète des singes
[Musique]
ensemble
sauge
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
stationnement tourner au même phénomène
[Musique]
azad me retire lambert et moi quelques
jours à marquer d'abord rappelé qu'en
terme à sa fin comme dan nos craintes et
bordeaux
[Musique]
donc on fait en sorte non voilà vêler
sa base comparable la nature à tous les
orateurs collaborer
ça va me rassurer
[Musique]
prépare toi ce qui va arriver jackson
storm appartient à la nouvelle
génération de coureurs high tech un
nouveau venu impressionnant jackson
store jackson store jackson storm est
unique en son genre salut champion
vous avez un beau palmarès
vous n'imaginez pas à quel point je suis
content de vous éliminer
excusez moi j'ai pas bien compris
m'éliminer vous avez très bien compris
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu ne seras plus jamais le courage que
tu as été
on ne peut pas remonter le temps petit
mais on peut remettre les pendules à
l'heure le manque de la compétition
automobile est en train de changer
tapis de course soufflerie réalité
virtuelle nos équipes travaillent et
simulateurs de course interactif vous
voulez on a un peu de boulot je suis
trop contente de pouvoir centre en train
de battre secours
ban
[Musique]
la plage bas valais chaque semaine des
vétérans renoncer à la compétition pour
céder la place à de jeunes coureurs plus
rapide
vous envisagez de prendre votre retraite
oui on parle des photos mais elle s'y
apparente
tu seras jamais plus rapide que ce tome
mais tu peux être plus malin que lui
bonne chance dit vont en avoir besoin
c'est moi qui déciderai quand je vous le
paraître
ne gagnera pas
je vais m'occuper de toi storm
[Applaudissements]
les meufs ça va être le week-end le plus
dément toute la vie
[Musique]
c'est énorme cette soirée je préfère
faire plus souvent
si on se trouvait un très petit valentin
du temps quelqu'un l'a vu me vautrer
maintenant tu t'es vautré ok je suis
tombé raide ce qui porta sur les
tablettes font sur la braguette
jardi j'ai eu ma dose
monsieur est ce que ça va monsieur je ne
sais pas ce qu'il faut faire gaffe
cardiaque
je vais regarder un tuto sur youtube il
est mort au rat [__] tu es génial faut
appeler la police
on n'appelle pas la police on nettoie
tout et ensuite on appelle la police
faut virer toute la drogue je gère on a
des virées pas ce qui fait que quelqu'un
nous dise clairement ce que je dois
faire et ensuite je ferai ce qu'on me
dit 1
déjà faudrait qu'on appelle un avocat
mon oncle jack tout ça a tout l'air
d'être un accident surtout ne touchez
pas au corps il se trouve qu elle a déjà
déplacé
faut qu'on se débarrasse de lui on n'a
pas envie de nous bien sûr que l'on a
pas d'autre solution
j'étais sûr que tout va bien
ouais c'est pas super
c'est vrai que dans ce périple en force
dès qu'ils en place
et si jamais on croise quelqu'un tu
rigoles a sorti dans la rue aura
personne j'adore votre banane dont
j'attends l'avis de bien deux jedi
comment une fête pour manger là toutes
les deux ans j'ai fait le meilleur moyen
des gens le trouvaient pour gérer le
stress
vous en voulez un bout
[Musique]
elsa faut dire qu'elle salue des dépôts
de chine catch up nude de mousse pour
aider haïti match devient d'abord je
serai au sytral et où christophe premier
disque l'usmo ce moment
[Musique]
la recrue dessous
habituellement
thatagat
celle ci
jean haget
et la russie
[Musique]
adam scott hoch
la grèce
[Musique]
mais ça va venir
cela
là
là c'est moi je m'appelle la glaise
j'avais une petite vie bien tranquille
sa vamp leurs données j'adorais mon
métier je provoquer des accidents
les crash tests t'es pas au courant au
courant de quoi en plus tu connais vous
d'elle même en cette lettre nous
expliquer que les ij était plus rentable
et que elle elle était localisée à
l'étranger 1 castrés avec a eu je crois
que je vais garder mon emploi vous vous
voulez être muté en inde c'est bien pour
vivre l'un d'eux tu vas aller [__] en
inde tu vas faire ça
j'ai déjà pris ma décision j'aimerais
bien avec toi ça devait pas été
compliqué de leurs noces tu ne vois tu
es ou perles en voiture
[Musique]
tu parle pas beaucoup toi le pen fort au
bras chômage
souvent les français tu t'en vas quand
même dans la fin de contrat
we going to enjoy
ça a bien touché un petit creux non oui
mon chat non
moi j'ai ton
[Musique]
j'étais pas quelqu'un qui manifestaient
qu'ils séquestraient des dirigeants qui
pourraient l'aider pneus ou qui avaient
indiqué ces droits je suis au milieu du
désert ya des militaires partout j'ai
été juste quelqu'un qui préférait
accepter un boulot de merde en inde
plutôt que de se remettre en question
c'est pour ça que je continue
[Musique]
you very bad trip
ça c'est non avec des masques
montmagny
ça c'est mon cas
génial papa matin
s
et
sourire à ses vassaux clavera
m
discours concomitamment à venir
[Musique]
non mais
[Applaudissements]
ses partenaires
[Musique]
marie cissé
parce qu'avant
m
[Musique]